this is a big mistake that I see many  people do when it comes to cover letters  many people write lots of things in  their cover letters what their  motivation is for the role where they  are the right fit for the role and so on  and so forth and there's nothing wrong  with that but in the end of the day the  cover letter should be the letter that  accompanies your application so make  sure to very early in the letter clearly  State what the role is that you are  applying to clearly State when you would  be available to start third clearly  State also which offers if relevant you  might want to start at these are  essential information that should be  included in oil cover letters full of  them are query advice